[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à tous dans
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités une émission
dédiée à celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département et ce
mercredi 22 mars parole à claudine canal
et président de l'association les poids
plumes
une association qui soutient les
personnes en situation de surpoids et
obèses vous évoqueront notamment avec
elle le rôle de l'association une
nouvelle antenne est ouverte depuis le
début de l'année à trappes parole aussi
dans cette émission à stéphane la faune
réveillac le président de maille
exclusive collectionne une marque de
parfums qu'il s'est hier son nouveau
produit phare à l'hôtel de france à
versailles un nouveau produit signé
jean-paul guerlain mais on débute donc
cette émission les 7-8 les invités avec
claudine canal et bonsoir bonsoir
claudine canal et vous êtes la
présidente de l'association les poids
plumes
vous intervenez notamment sur le champ
de l'obésité depuis 2012 et vous est
implanté désormais dans les yvelines
depuis le début 2010 est au sein de
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien à
trappes
expliquez-nous brièvement quel est votre
rôle au sein d'établissements qu'est ce
que vous y faites quelques actions vous
y mener alors je travaille en
collaboration avec les équipes médicales
et paramédicales qui prennent en charge
donc les personnes qui sont en situation
d'obésité ou en surpoids et qui se
prennent en main c'est qu'elle le dire
parce que je pense que déjà d'aller vers
l'hôpital pour se prendre en charge
c'est important c'est parce que c'est
une maladie les personnes ne la
perçoivent pas du tout comme une maladie
cette cette situation tout le monde
pense que c'est un état de fait mais
c'est vraiment une maladie chronique et
donc notre action effectivement c'est
d'accompagner tous les patients qui se
prennent en charge
aba'a les accompagner pendant le
parcours pour effectivement
être assurée puisque l'association est
constituée principalement de personnes
qui sont dans le même parcours et qui
ont déjà vécu on n'a pas de regard
négatif on est on n'a pas de tabou donc
les gens viennent avec vers nous pour
chercher de l'information va évoquer ce
point justement mais juste pour revenir
sur votre présence au sein de l'hôpital
ce ne sont pas du coup que les gens qui
vont se faire opérer qui viennent vous
voir ce sont des gens qui font juste la
démarche tout simplement de venir vous
voir vous occuper des gens qui seront
opérées et non et si opérations vous
vous occupez de aussi avant et après
tout à fait donc ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que effectivement la personne qui
ne rentrent pas dans les clous ben on en
fait quoi
on la laisse sur le trottoir non c'est
pas du tout le but de l'association
c'est effectivement d'aider à se sentir
mieux et essayer de trouver une solution
avec eux dans ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
mettre en place pour effectivement
travailler le plus sur eux-mêmes et
essayer de sortir de cette problématique
l'avantagent vous le disiez de votre
association ce que c'est des gens qui
ont vécu ça ou qui vivent ça aussi
l'obésité et du coup ça facilite quoi
expliquer nous c'est la parole on se
libère plus facilement on parle plus
facilement on s'exprime plus facilement
retourner dans une telle situation
alors oui on s'exprime vis-à-vis des
gens qui ont effectivement le même
parcours parce que ben il ya des choses
il ya l'inconnue en fait quand on entame
un parcours ya l'inconnu puisque un
parcours c'est très très lourd ça dure
minimum
donc on va parler de la prise en charge
par rapport à l'obésité
si on décide de se faire opérer c'est un
parcours très long qui durent minimum 6
mois ça c'est des recommandations de la
haute autorité de santé
effectivement ben on est rassuré parce
que pendant ces six mois on est en
période de réflexion
on se prend en charge aussi bien sûr un
niveau un plan nutritionnel diététique
on essaie de se remettre en activité
physique mais bon c'est vrai que quand
on est en surcharge pondérale c'est
compliqué on essaie aussi bas on est
analysée en fait sur toutes les coutures
puisqu'on à une série d'examens
effectivement quand on franchit le bloc
on sait que on est prêt pour ce type
d'opération puisque en fait au bout des
six mois il ya une réunion qui s'appelle
la réunion curé disciplinaire puisque
c'est un c'est un parcours multi dits
multi disciplinaire où il ya plein de
pathologie qui se plaint de d'acteurs de
la santé qui sont dans des médecins est
effectivement pour avoir l'aval il faut
effectivement qu'on passe le cap de la
corde 7
17 réunions alors on parlait de
l'accompagnement l'accompagnement avant
l'accompagnement après aussi c'est pas
parce que par exemple on commence à
perdre du poids c'est pas parce qu'on
s'est fait opérer que on peut être tout
seul tout le temps je vais génie de
avoir des coups bas lance des remises en
question justement justement est
justement la problématique c'est que les
personnes pensent justement pendant là
quand on franchit pas effectivement oui
on se fait opérer
on appelle ça la lune de miel pendant
deux ans on va perdre beaucoup de poids
donc il ya différentes techniques je
vais peut-être pas vous les énoncés on
pourra venir les découvrir dès demain
nous ont fait une réunion joyeusement
amadora plusieurs formations réunions
d'information sur tout le parcours
obésité est ce que ça comporte pas ce
que les gens pensent que c'est facile
mais c'est pas simple parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de psychologie dedans donc
avant effectivement a suivi donc comme
on l'a nommé notre thématique la réunion
d'information le suivi pré up
oui mais le suivi post up is rock post
up on parle d'opération way
préopératoire oui et post opératoire
aussi aussi parce que c'est un parcours
qui est malheureusement c'est un combat
qui va durer toute sa vie on est tout le
temps obèse on ne guérit pas de cette
maladie c'est une maladie c'est normal
il faut insister là-dessus et l'allemand
qui nous écoutent on parle bien d'une
maladie on parle pas de gens qui sont
comme tout le monde et qui mange juste
un peu plus et qui du coup ne viennent
plus gros c'est une manière il ya plein
de facteurs qui rentrent en compte six à
la génétique effectivement il ya
certainement la mauvaise alimentation
il faut rappeler aussi que les personnes
qui sont touchées par l'obésité en
général et il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui sont en précarité qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de moyens
ils peuvent pas effectivement s'offrir
de la qualité donc il n'ya pas il ya
aussi l'effet sédentaires puisque puis
on amasse de poids effectivement au
moins on va ça va être facile de se
déplacer et c'est super important et
nous ont dit effectivement aux personnes
que l'on prend en charge qu'il faut
qu'ils restent dans leur tête il faut
que dans un petit coin de leur cerveau
ils savent que c'est un suivi à
villebois une dernière question très
rapidement on rappelle que du coup de
main soit une réunion d'information qui
est organisée à trappes
on peut avoir plus d'informations sur
votre site internet www.labopharm.com
juste rapidement sur cette soirée
d'information ont veillé à prendre quoi
très rapidement elle encaisse convoyés à
prendre et ben en fait on va expliquer
pourquoi il faut se prendre en charge
il ya divers différents intervenants qui
vont venir
donc il y aura un nutritionniste you lie
à une psychologue un chirurgien
l'association aussi puisque elle joue
comme je vous ai dis hein
forcément c'est vraiment un acteur du
parcours puisque à l'accompagner ca
vient enrichir effectivement tout
parcours et on va donc à comprendre
pourquoi on est dans cet état
comment on peut se prendre en charge il
ya des solutions l'obésité est bien
remboursés par la sécurité sociale au
niveau de l'intervention
donc je pense que il faut vraiment qu'on
soit acteur quoi merci claudine canal et
d'être venu en plateau merci pour vos
réponses plus d'informations du coup sur
www.lepoint.fr org merci à vous
[Musique]
on prend à présent la direction de
versailles sans transition une soirée de
lancement pour la nouvelle marque de
parfums mallet exclusive collection
était organisée collectionne excusez moi
était organisée hier soir dans les
salons de l'hôtel de france a précipité
du château notre journaliste michael et
demi d'euros étaient sur place pour
rencontrer le président de la marque à
l'occasion de cette soirée de gala
regarder alors ce soir grande soirée à
versailles à l'hôtel de france je suis
avec stéphane la fondent réveillac le
créateur de la nouvelle collection m'a x
libre collectionne il va nous parler
justement de cette nouvelle marque qui
vient de se créer en partenariat
si on peut le dire avec jean paul
guerlain alors stéphane expliquez-nous
un petit peu pourquoi vous élancer cette
nouvelle collection
écoutez tout et tout ça est le fruit
d'une rencontre c'est une rencontre
exceptionnelle
un vrai cadeau de la vie rencontré jean
paul guerlain qui est fondamentalement
le plus grand nez au monde existant qui
a donc laissé pendant une cinquantaine
d'années le nez de la maison guerlain et
qui a aujourd'hui 80 ans et qui s'est
remis à la création et
jean-paul travail pour nous maintenant
et on nous allons accompagner ses
créances pourquoi jean paul guerlain
c'est parce que c'est le plus grand on
peut le dire c'est le plus grand il est
vivant il a laissé une trace incroyable
dans la parfumerie c'est quelqu'un
d'assez le délicieux très jeune dans sa
tête vous a fait des fragrances
extrêmement moderne qu'on a la chance de
faire découvrir ce soir en
avant-première et votre collection
justement est-ce que vous nous en dire
un peu plus sur cette collection qui va
sûrement dans quelques mois alors
exactement le la collection sortira lé
premier parfum sortiront en fin d'année
cette question est à la fois je vous
dédie une collection moderne avec des
jus à la fois destiné pour le
moyen-orient mais aussi peut-être déjà
eu assez classique assez guerlain en
fait que retrouver dans les créations de
jean paul quel est l'objectif
quand on crée un nouveau parfum on sait
que le secteur est ultra concurrentiel
il ya guerlain justement aussi qu'il
sera va vendre l'un de vos concurrents
oui est ce que vous êtes complémentaire
est ce que vous êtes dit ceci on est sûr
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est une start-up
la chance que l'on a c'est qu'on l'a on
a le nez le nez vraiment connu au niveau
mondial à nouveau monsieur jean paul
guerlain
on veut faire différent c'est à dire
qu'on veut vraiment s'inscrire dans la
tradition de la haute parfumerie
française avec des matières naturelles
et encore une fois d'avoir monsieur
guerlain créateur est à l'origine de ces
créations c'est une chance
extraordinaire
d'où ce cadre ici à versailles c'est
aussi l'objectif de créer une histoire
autour de ce nouveau parfum qui n'en a
pas finalement pour exactement c'est
c'est une nouvelle aventure
on a voulu aussi montrer l'univers
autour de monsieur guerlain
c'est un homme très érudit très cultivé
qui adore la la culture la littérature
la musique et ce soir il est entouré
d'artistes de jeunes talents il ya simon
gray chi qui est un des plus grands
pianistes au monde
qui nous fait la joie de nous
accompagner c'est vraiment une aventure
une jolie aventure humaine avec des
jeunes talents est très prometteur
parlez nous de cette start up il ya
combien d'employés est ce que vous êtes
prêts à lancer ce parfum écoutez on est
encore tout petit en terme d'emploi y
est les parfums sont prêts on est dans
les starting blocks
on a déjà des financiers on continue le
tour de table on vous promet d'être très
belle nouvelle pour les prochaines
semaines il ya un objectif en france où
un objectif à l'international l'objectif
est à la fois en france et international
la renommée de monsieur guerlain
on a cette chance exceptionnelle que ma
ce soir des gens du qatar d'arabie
saoudite les états unis d'asie qui
viennent nous voir on a la télé chinoise
on a un certain nombre de gens vous êtes
là aussi c'est vraiment une renommée
mondiale et c'est extrêmement précieux
points et comment séduire justement ces
nouveaux marchés c'est ce marché
asiatique ce marché du moyen-orient
comment les séduire est-ce que c'est
fait pour les séduire ce nouveau parfum
effectivement l'idée dans la collection
de fragrances est vraiment d'avoir un
choix suffisamment large
monsieur guerlain a énormément travaillé
et voyager tout au long de sa carrière
et c'est une chance parce qu'il connaît
exactement quelles sont les goûts des
différents pays et je crois qu'on a
vraiment une palette qui va permettre de
séduire justement différentes cultures
différents horizons
à partir de quand vous avez dit si les
vous lancer dans cette aventure c'est
une aventure qui a démarré il ya presque
deux ans maintenant
donc c'est vraiment un travail qui a été
fait on a aujourd'hui une collection
assez large parfum
et c'est vraiment un travail qui était
passionnant moi j'ai découvert le milieu
la parfumerie que je ne connaissais pas
je me sens entouré aussi d'une équipe
qui ont accompagné et maintenant
quelques associés et voilà nous sommes
là pour vraiment encadré monsieur
guerlain et l'aider à mettre les parfums
sur le marché c'est vraiment un vrai
cadeau qui veut nous faire a toujours je
me suis garé l'un est là pour vous juste
pour une opération d'une seule fois un
one shot comme on dit où il sera là dans
le temps il va nous aider à vous
conseiller
il sera là dans le temps il est vraiment
très précieux c'est vraiment un travail
qui se fait en équipe c'est pas
uniquement dans la création que ce soit
aussi dans la communication que ce soit
dans l'accompagnement il est vraiment
important que monsieur guerlain avait
soit avec nous et il est très heureux
d'être là ce soir et voilà on a près de
400 personnes ce soir à versailles et
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'important
est ce qu'on peut imaginer un jour votre
collection à côté de guerlain à côté des
autres grands parfums français et
internationaux écoutez on a encore
beaucoup de chemin la maison guerlain
est une maison magnifique on
on n'est pas aujourd'hui évidemment on
est tout petit à côté de maison guerlain
ou d'autres grandes maisons de parfum
encore une fois notre chance c'est
d'être des djeun d'être accompagné par
des jeunes talents c'est tout un en
ville un univers autour de monsieur
guerlain et je crois que ça crée une
réelle dynamique que c'est ça qui est
bien merci beaucoup stéphane pinto et
bon courage pour cette soirée je pense
que vous allez avoir besoin il ya 400
convives quand même versé à vous et
merci à merci à plusieurs c'est la fin
de ce set 8 les invités toutes nos
séquences sont à retrouver en replay sur
tv fil 78 points comme bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]